excuse me could i ask you a question
i think this is the weirdest
conversation you and i have ever had
this is barcelona and this is alex
rawlings he's a i am a journalist a
writer and a filmmaker and a polyglot
[Music]
he's also the author of how to speak any
language fluently i spent my whole life
telling people about the benefits of
learning languages and learning
languages myself so a better person to
help us test this a brand new pocket
talk device which is a live translator
which in theory should replace the need
of learning foreign languages to see
whether i can communicate with people in
barcelona using it
[Music]
why did we pick this translator a few
reasons with the click of one button it
can translate 82 different languages and
it claims to translate conversations not
just statements
set the languages i'm setting the
input language to
english uk and the output language to
spanish
spain
it has noise cancelling microphones and
speakers so speak in one language and
out comes another we have a microphone
on this side a speaker and a microphone
on this side so presumably you can use
it like this to talk it's smaller than a
smartphone but it still has a
touchscreen and it comes with two years
of cellular data so those traveling
don't need to worry about an
international data plan this feels like
a very comfortable thing to have in my
pocket very easy to whip out whenever i
need it and it's extremely light
actually i barely feel
like i've got a device in my hand at all
it also has a camera for translating
signs and menus
they cost 299 dollars but is it worth it
so i've designed three tests today to
see how well the pocket talk device
performs
[Music]
first up we're going to try for a simple
typical tourist interaction
could i have a coffee with soy milk
please
okay so the first erection seemed to go
quite well uh she didn't seem to react
weirdly to me speaking to her through a
live translation machine and when she
brought my coffee she brought soy milk
so that passed the test as well
[Music]
could you tell me the way to the
cathedral please
one second
sorry could you tell me that again i'm
not sure i understood what was the way
to the cathedral please
uh
[Music]
i'm not sure it fully understood my
accent i'm not sure it really understood
the person in the streets accent at some
point when i asked do you know the way
to the cathedral i think it thought i
said do you know the weight of the
cathedral there are also moments where i
think it took a really long time to
actually translate so i'm trying to stop
someone in the street who's in a rush
and luckily barcelona is a relaxed city
so it's not such a big problem so i'd
say that
i'm not sure we can say that it passed
that test
now for the hardest trial that i'm going
to put this device through this is my
friend ash he's a tattoo artist from
egypt who's been living here in
barcelona and normally when we see each
other we speak english but this time
he's going to speak to me in egyptian
arabic
when this device is speaking arabic do
you understand it very well what are the
things that it's translating what is it
not translating
[Music]
[Music]
it is fine it is necessary to answer the
arabic language in egypt but work is in
a hospital with a translator all words
translate correct words and wrong words
i didn't understand any of the
translation of what ash was saying at
all it was saying all sorts of weird
words weird construction ash said that
it understood my english very well and
it was translating my english into
pretty good standard arabic
but the thing with arabic is that
everybody speaks regional languages so
as for the devices claim that it is able
to pick up and translate colloquial
language in a really good way i've got
to say
i'm not entirely sure that was a success
a pocket talk spokesman said we are
constantly updating our software to
improve performance translating slang in
various dialects can be difficult to get
right 100 of the time he added the speed
of translation depends on the strength
of the user's signal
so where did alex net out i would
probably give this device three stars
it's a great piece of kit it's a great
size it's very portable and for basic
transactions buying things in shops it
definitely does what it's supposed to do
but if you have aspirations of being
more than just a transactional person in
a foreign country i don't think this
device is really going to cut it
[Music]
no
[Music]